today we are talking about business
development how to use content to bring
in immediate business and we're going to
talk about client Outreach the first
strategy of client Outreach involves
zero content so you don't even have to
make content if you're struggling at the
point right now where like I need to
make money right now it's not working
you don't even have to make content yet
and I'm going to show you the strategy
that we've used multiple times that I've
invested into entrepreneurs and we've
done one high six figure business two
mid six figure business one low
six-figure business uh that's Zach he
hit his path for six figures in three
weeks of doing this when I'm looking at
Zach or Drew or Beau or Jeremy the
people that I've invested in and we go
through this process I want at least a 2
000 a month fine thinking who can pay us
two thousand dollars a month and part of
the problem with a lot of our Outreach
is you're targeting people who cannot
pay you so if you're targeting people
who don't have any kind of budget they
might have a need but if they don't have
budget you're not making money but if
it's hard for them to pay fifty dollars
a month that's not an ideal client for
you so we target people who the minimum
is 2 a month and an ideal is 3 500 plus
per month okay so I'm going to show you
the process that we go through here so
Step One is make a list of clients who
can't pay you right and what I want to
do in our breakout sessions is
brainstorm together who are the types of
potential people who are potential
clients for us or partners for us so
we're making a list of clients who can
actually pay us
who can afford a thousand bucks a month
500 bucks a month 2 000 bucks a month
3500 bucks a month right uh some of the
cases it's five figures per month but
who can afford to pay you at least a
couple thousand dollars a month for the
thing you're going to be providing right
it starts to really change who we're
going often who we're targeting
so again ideally two thousand dollars
plus per month
and this is where it's often easier to
go up to businesses than it is to go
after consumers so not a lot of
individuals will be able to pay you two
thousand dollars a month
but businesses can't
if you're solving a business problem for
people and it's really helping them
it's easier to get the money because
they have budget and it's easier to
maintain it so that it's happening every
month
every month every month every month
every month every month the first brand
deal that I got was I was writing
content
for a big telecommunications company
here in Canada and I was I was writing a
bunch of content and trying to sell my
content and
um through articles and wasn't making
any money and waiting on advertisements
to start to come in but you need huge
skill to do that and says okay well I
can I can write great articles and
instead of just writing for my website
instead of just writing for one person
I'm going to write for a corporate blog
and they paid me I think the first one
was 500 bucks to do a one-off and then
that led to a thousand bucks and 1500
bucks and 2 000 bucks and I kept
increasing the value and they kept
increasing how much they paid me but
because it's a business it fits in well
they have budget you're solving a
problem and
it's an ongoing problem so so they need
you to continue to ongoingly solve it
for them okay so I'm thinking about our
clients I want you thinking people can
actually afford to pay you part of the
biggest problem is we're not talking to
people who can actually
pay us they just don't have the budget
to pay us
okay I'm looking at Peter here he makes
these awesome
um animation videos of me you know that
he shares on Instagram cool approach
businesses and say hey I do these
animation videos
I will make a video per week for you or
per day for you I don't know how long it
takes Peter to make these videos and
it's gonna cost two thousand bucks a
month right we start to get clients
because we're solving a problem
okay so that's step one make a list step
two is we're gonna Outreach to them and
offer three big Ideas hey I've got three
big ideas for how you can blank so
inside of YouTube world if you're
looking at Zack or Jew or Jeremy where
we're doing YouTube Consulting with
people it's like I've got three big
ideas for how you can go from 10 000
subscribers to a hundred thousand
subscribers or if you're at 100 to go
from 100 000 to 500 000 subscribers if
they're already at 500 to go from 500
000 to 10 million subscribers and so on
right I've got three big ideas for how
you can get X so what is the X you can
provide people what is the result that
you're going to be able to provide
people
and you have three big ideas for how
they can accomplish that
then you reach out to them and email and
then social so email you may be able to
find their email you may not be able to
but you're looking to see if you can
find your email and in social media
wherever they are active on social
and maybe that's Twitter maybe that's
LinkedIn maybe that's Instagram who
knows maybe that's a tick tock where are
they actually active themselves on
social media and then that's what we're
going to be doing some Outreach to them
to say you've got your two big ideas
that you'd love to share with them
and then you go on a call with them not
everybody says yes right this becomes a
if you only have three people on your
list that's a problem right we need to
build a big list of people so that in
the Outreach process some people will
never see it some people will ignore you
and then some people say yes and they
hop on a call and then you go through
your ideas
from that call
we're just given the value we're just
here are three big Ideas like take it
run with it go do it yourself amazing if
you need help I can help you do it too I
have a business that does this but here
are your three big Ideas so if
somebody's coming on a call to talk
about their YouTube channel to go from
50 000 subscribers to 100 here are the
three big Ideas go do it you have a team
awesome execute it yourself
I can help or Zach can help or Drew can
help or Jeremy can help right
from there you'll get 30 to 50 percent
of people who then want to sign up and
go do the thing with you if you've
targeted your list a lot
some people may not want to do it some
people may not be ready some people may
not be in the right spot yet and So for
anybody who we all hop on a call with
who then doesn't say yes right away we
add them to what we call our value
emails list and on the value emails list
every two weeks we send a value email
around the thing that they care about
Okay so
in the YouTube world uh Drew might send
an email about thumbnails right okay
here are the latest findings we have
about thumbnails or here's an experiment
that we ran on title split test or
here's how you can use your newsletter
list to grow your YouTube channel right
it's it's just value it's not hey are
you ready to buy yet hey hello I'm still
here can you hire me right so we're not
doing follow-up emails there are no
follow-up emails they they buy on the
call or they don't and if they don't
they're added to the client to the value
emails list and then every two weeks you
send a value email around the thing that
you're an expert at
just giving pure value and then the last
sentence can be hey and if you're ready
to blank right if you're ready to grow
your YouTube channel I'm happy to help
but it's not a sales email it's a value
you're educating and you're teaching and
what some people will do
maybe they take that email and they just
do the work themselves cool they give it
to their team and say hey copy what this
person told me to do great some people
look at and say wow you're really an
expert at this and you're still giving
me tons of value I want to how can I
work with you how can I hire you and for
some people it's just a matter of timing
like they're swamped they're overwhelmed
they've got a million things going on
and they're not ready but now they are
and every time we've done this when
we've built up a list of people you hop
on some calls and some people who don't
say yes cool you add them to the list
and then you add send the value add
emails it might be somebody that you
talked to six months ago but now they're
ready
and maybe they've been seeing your
emails every two weeks or six months and
they never responded but then now they
respond and they say I'm ready
so we often get caught on this trap of
like following up and waiting for people
don't wait for people go out and do more
Outreach
and now they're getting the value adds
email every two weeks and off that list
is always somebody that you can that
comes back and says yes I was just
talking to Zach yesterday like should I
should I
drum up more business before the end of
the year it's like the easiest way to do
is just send out the value email
those people are reading the list who
know you who you've talked to who you've
done a quick audit for of their YouTube
channel send out that value email
and so what it does is keep you top of
mind the whole point here is to stay top
of mind for that you know they're
interested but it's not their most
important priority they have a million
other things that they're worried about
but in three months maybe it does become
their top priority and you've been
educating them for the past three months
over and over and over again so the
whole point is to stay top of mind so
that when they're ready you're the
person they come and they want to work
with
so the three points are make a list of
clients who can pay you this is the big
one because most of us are targeting
people who can't afford to pay us a
thousand two thousand dollars a month
offer them three big ideas on a call
and then add them to the value email
list if they don't sign up right away
we are diving into some awesome new
new the nine step ultimate coaching
process
part two get their buy-in this now
becomes important okay what's really
really really really really really
really critical is you have to help them
see what you see
your job as a coach is to help somebody
see a greater potential for their life
you see something in them you see a path
for them that they don't think is
possible
which is partly why they haven't done
anything on it they don't think that
they can get to that other spot and your
hope your inspiration your message your
belief is the thing that will help guide
them through
right there's a expression in in sales
and persuasion and whoever is more
confident wins
you have to be more confident in their
future than they are lacking confidence
in their future
if I just absolutely believe that you
could be the greatest that you actually
have Michael Jordan level genius at
something and I'm steadfast in that and
there's no knocking me down off of that
then you might start to doubt your own
like oh maybe he's right maybe I can do
this and it's that little seed of hope
that you want to gift to other people so
you see that in them hopefully right you
have to you have to find a path in
talking to them to see a great potential
for them
and then help them see what you see so
last night we had a guy in our stream uh
zanju and I do we do a gaming stream
where I play League of Legends and we
answer business questions along the way
and we had a guy pop on
uh named Charming Fox and he his first
question was talking about his parents
business and how he
really doesn't like being in his parents
business you know at some point he wants
to be able to leave the parents business
do his own thing but he feels guilty
about being you know not leaving them
alone and not having the support for
them anymore and he's got to figure out
you know how much is enough to pay them
back and to help them and then where
does he go to next
after we got into that discussion he
started changing a topic and going off
all of these crazy tangents super crazy
questions that I've never been asked
before that were totally unrelated I
don't remember maybe Zen remember some
of them some of them were crazy maybe
Drew might remember some of them too
um just totally Off the Wall crazy
questions
and after the the third or fourth one we
called him out and said hey Charming Fox
we could help you here
right like we could actually help you
make a meaningful change in your life
you've got this issue in your family
business that you want to get out and
you don't know where you're going to go
to next and you're asking us about yeah
you put in the chat only fans he was
asking about how does a man make it on
only fans and how does I mean a bunch of
unrelated questions to where he wants to
go
let's use this time to actually help you
and here's the path is that you are a
super creative person
I can tell because of all of these
creative ideas that you're coming up
with all these creative questions that
you're you're popping into the stream
just kind of have fun but you're
distracted from the thing that actually
matters is here you got to fix this
thing in your life
if you can use that creativity and point
it in a powerful Direction you could be
unstoppable
the problem is you're using your
creativity to just run around in circles
and avoid the thing that matters the
most
so it's giving him the push it's given
him uh exposing the truth we're getting
a little bit Raw
but it's helping him see what I see is
like this is a creative genius
and he may not see that in himself
and so that's your job every time you
got somebody in front of you
and this doesn't just apply to coaching
this is the being a parent being you
know being a friend you see something in
somebody that they don't necessarily
seeing themselves and even you just
validating it and recognizing it is the
thing that can they can hold on to
to then give them the momentum to go
actually make some kind of change in
their life so you have to help them see
what you see otherwise they won't listen
to the advice like okay great strategy
yep check check
but I can't do that uh it worked it
worked for Zan sure it works for Evan
awesome it works for Jennifer fantastic
but that won't work for me you don't
have their buy-in
okay
okay next this is important objections
excuses and defensiveness
if you don't get to a point where they
are giving you pushback
I don't think you've done a good enough
job as a coach I think you're on the
wrong issue or you haven't gone deep
enough
if they're coming on and they're talking
to you and you're just saying the advice
and they say yep yep yep great okay
perfect thank you
they're likely not going to do it and
you haven't gone deep enough you have to
get to some point of objections excuses
or defensiveness
because that's the actual story that
they're telling themselves that's the
actual reason why they're not taking
action they've had this goal for however
many years and haven't done anything on
it because of this belief system
that nobody has challenged them on in a
loving way
so that's the job you have to get to
that point where it's rise now some
people will get emotional like you know
this woman we did an IG lab together and
she started crying
um everybody has their own patterns then
uh will debate you
Zayn well Zane won't cry usually on
stream but he'll debate you and say you
know but what about this and what about
this and what about this it's like okay
great I'm on the right issue if I can
get Zan into debate mode it's like okay
we're touching something good we're
about to make a breakthrough right so
everybody will have their own emotional
response but it's still around excuses
defensiveness and objections and you
have to be able to you have to be able
to touch it and a lot of coaches here
then they back off like oh I didn't mean
that like no no like it's on the other
side of that objection that you actually
make the Breakthrough for them
so them getting defensive is not is not
they may even say hurtful things to you
just let it bounce
it's not about you this is this is how
they react when they're being poked like
you've hit a raw nerve this is great you
might be the only person who has the
patience to love the understanding to
sit with them to help them and Coach
them to get through the other side the
other thing here is make sure you don't
go down past it don't serve them so
you've got this direction of where you
want to take people when people get to
defensive mode they pull up all sorts of
different examples they're trying to
find you know a reason why your plan
isn't going to work
sometimes it's worth addressing those if
it gets you to where you need to go but
a lot of times it's just a distraction
like Charming Fox last night who's
talking about how do I make a business
as a man on only fans it's like that's
not the question that actually matters
so we could spend an hour talking about
that but it actually doesn't solve the
problem that he's got and this is this
is classic when you hit on a point of of
uh of being a raw nerve
a classic objection exclusive
defensiveness is to distract
to take the conversation somewhere else
because this is too touchy to talk about
and he later admitted I usually don't
like to think about this or talk about
this like but this is the only thing
that matters Charming Fox this is where
your creativity needs to go
and so we can easily get sidetracked
and you have to watch out as a coach not
to let that happen because what they say
is an example
may have tons of flaws in it tons of
holes and it's a tendency to want to
jump on those and say no no you haven't
thought that out and address this
distraction problem
don't even talk about it
I don't want to focus there
we're focused on this we're focused on
you getting out of your family business
or you figuring out what your passion is
or you like whatever this challenge is
in front of that's what we need to solve
and so it's it's not just okay it should
be
standard that you get some kind of
objection excuses defensiveness
distraction change the topic move
somewhere else and everybody else in
their life they've
not manipulated but found our way to
okay I'm I'm I'm being hit with a raw
nerve so I'm going to distract or I'm
going to tell a joke or I'm going to do
something that and it works for them so
then they don't have to come back to the
raw issue
and that's your job is to sit with them
to not allow those things to happen and
to keep coming back to help them to
serve them to love them right
uh so I'm a huge believer that if you
haven't touched on a raw nerve you
haven't gone deep enough or you're on
the wrong issue you're not actually
solving the right problem
um it doesn't mean again everybody has
to cry when they're with you people will
react differently but there is some form
of defensiveness that pops up
um be loving but firm
they have to feel your love
they have to feel that you care
because
when they get into defensive mode all
their hearing is them being attacked
they feel attacked you're not trying to
attack them this is where again people
get into conflict it's like I'm trying
to serve you I'm trying to help you but
they feel attacked it's not it's not
your intent it's how they're receiving
it
so you have to do the pattern interrupt
so that they feel not judged but they
feel loved
most people will not give them a loving
push forward
most people in our lives in their lives
think about what happens there's either
the camp of they're trying to push you
somewhere
you should do this you should do that
you should go take that job you should
marry this person you should everybody's
got an opinion on what you should do
with your life right everybody's got
some kind of you shouldn't do that who
are you to think you can go through this
thing right so they're being judged
the people who are are then loving you
often don't ever push you they just say
it'll be okay they give you the hug they
give you words of affirmation they'll
support you but they don't know how to
help you
and again listen alone is value but what
you want to do is combine it you're
giving a loving push forward
you have to get here because if you
don't get here you're not gonna you're
never gonna realize your potential
you're going to be you're gonna you're
gonna be upset and sad and depressed and
this problem that's happening right now
will continue to happen for you until we
address it and it's possible and I'm
here to help and I'm here to tell you
that you can do it I'm giving you
strategies to actually do it
and I'm not going to let you up the hook
and disappoint yourself again
right when I talked about wearing their
skin
the idea is you become the best version
of themselves
uh when I talked to Zan we came up with
Zen 2025 so when I'm talking to Zane in
2021 I I just become Zen 2025.
I'm not even me anymore I am future you
like what would say in 2025 tell Zane
2021 and that's the message that I try
to share
the loving push forward
one thing that's super weird that may
fit or may not is I'll say I love you a
lot in coaching sessions
I'm going hard I'm pushing them forward
I'm helping them realize where they need
to go and when they get defensive say I
love you
it throws them off
because they feel they're getting
attacked
but now they're feeling the love and
it's the pattern interrupt right now
only do it if it's genuine when I say it
it's genuine it's like I have so much
love for this person I even if I I've
just met you it's like I see so much
potential so much love inside you such a
gift
it needs to come out it needs to happen
and so that's a genuine thing that that
I say that's actually helped out a lot
in in coaching sessions if you can I
know love is a weird word and especially
guys have a hard time saying I love you
but if you can say that or say some kind
of compliment to again help them feel
loved even if you don't want to say love
that in the in the midst of them feeling
they've been hiding this wound for their
entire life but it's it's still there
because they're itching it and
scratching they're hiding don't they
don't want anybody to see it and then
now you've exposed it they feel extra
weak and extra insecure and then you
saying that you love them are you saying
how beautiful it is are you saying where
they could go like again just the
feeling to get their buy-in they have to
feel not judged and criticized because
if they feel judged and criticized they
shut down they won't listen to you they
won't take the action even if it's the
right strategy it doesn't matter if you
don't get their buy-in
so this step
is super super super super super super
important okay so the three steps to get
there by and help them see what you see
you have to get to a place where you get
some objections excuses defensiveness
and then be loving and firm that we are
not getting off this we have to get to
the other side and I'm going to do
whatever it takes to get you there
because I love you because I see this
greatness inside you it can happen
the daily to do and not to-do list now
I've done the to-do list a lot of times
the not to do part of it though was the
interesting thing that I had to really
think about and took me a lot longer
than expected so let me start with the
easy stuff the to-do list so I'm going
to walk you through what I do every day
every morning uh and and the different
calendars that I have and I'm going to
take it deeper than I've ever taken it
and any any presentation or speech my
morning starts with no alarm
so the to do is no alarm
and I'll you should go to bed at the
same time you go to bed around 11 and
read and then fall asleep maybe 11 30.
but I wake up with no alarm and I
haven't woken up to an alarm
I don't know maybe in a decade uh now if
I'm speaking and I have to be on stage
in the morning or traveling or something
then sure but day to day no alarm I just
basically let my body get the rest of
the needs so yesterday I woke up at
eight something this morning I woke up
at five something
I wake up when my body wakes up some
nights I need more rest some nights I
don't need as much rest and so I get up
right and so
um I I delayed the start of my day where
nothing really happens has to happen
until 10 o'clock so that I can get the
sleep that I need in my life Susie says
absolutely agree with that I mean I work
for everybody but telling you what works
for me
next the first thing I do after I wake
up
is intention for the day
I wake up you know I got lines on my
face I got stuff in my eyes you know
what day is it I don't even remember
what is my intention for the day this is
the first thing that I do so I go to the
bathroom and in the bathroom I'm looking
at my calendar for what's happening
today
and setting the intention okay oh today
what day is today it's Thursday it's
public facing day what's my intention I
have movement makers up first amazing
this is going to be great what's my
intention I want to serve the people
here in this group I want to help I want
to try to get the things that are inside
my head and and put into your head so
you can then spread your message out and
get it to other people's heads and so
what's the intention and different days
have different intentions for me even
even inside a day you might have
different intentions
the the background on my cell phone you
probably you probably can't see it too
small but it says remember your
intention
remember you're it's a constant
reminders moves what is my intention for
the day for this moment for right now
because if you wake up most people wake
up like an accident with zero intention
and you got hopes and dreams and
Ambitions and something inspires you and
you hope that makes a difference and it
might but we forget our intention
so when you live an intentional day it's
totally different than when you're
living an accidental day
next 30 breaths and then call ten cold
splashes on my face so 30 breasts is is
uh Wim Hof style so it'll be
like that 30 press just to start getting
some airflow going and then I I will
take the coldest water while I'm doing
that I have water on running and I'll
just then splash it on my face
just to wake up like good morning we set
Our intention no time like the present
to go kick us off let's go so 30 breaths
10 cold splashes every day then water
the goal is to drink one of these a day
I am about here since I woke up at five
so I'm about halfway through
a gallon a day you're dehydrated when
you wake up it's really hard to have
energy when you don't have water inside
you so super quick water then I do an
Eda scan and I don't know if you guys
have heard of this this was introduced
to me by Deepak Chopra when I did an
interview with him
I don't know about a month ago or a
couple weeks ago on the channel where
it's part of the Fitbit watch so Nina
and I both have the Fitbit watch and you
basically cover it with your hand and it
tracks your heartbeat
and the the shortest Eda scan you can do
is two minutes for them and your the
goal is just to calm your mind relax
just sit down and
have intention and and just let go of
Whatever anxiety you might have and then
it'll track your heartbeat over the
course so I can easily get my heartbeat
down from you know 80 90 to 60.
in two minutes
so every morning I just do a quick Eda
scan
um to remind myself then I take the dogs
out get some sun get some sun on your
face it makes a huge huge huge
difference having a dog forces that
but what on days where I don't take the
dogs out in the morning I don't get sun
I don't have as much energy
there's just something like getting some
even here in Toronto when it's it's
freezing and cold in Canada and it's
starting to get a little bit nice now
but even in the winter just getting
outside getting some fresh air even just
that idea of getting out of your your
home
changes the energy State when you come
back
for anybody who works at home this is
going to be really hard is that you
there's no separation between
waking up to then going to work
things blur too much so having some kind
of routine to make that transitioner
easier you're basically leaving the home
and coming back and when you're coming
back you're getting ready to go work
sun is vitamin D says Frank I also
stretch so this is going to be me every
time I'm outside because I'm standing on
the trampoline all day long and I'm
doing 20 to 40 000 jumps a day my
hamstrings get super tight so anytime
I'm outside with the dogs I'm stretching
out my hamstrings so if you see me doing
this I'm okay just getting my stretches
in
um exercise so then I'll go for a walk
or a run sometimes with Nina or
sometimes if she's not awake then I'll
go learn so this morning was no nina
time she woke up late so I went by
myself went for a run and I'll if I'm
with Nina then we'll we'll usually do a
walk they'll be you know 45 minutes and
we talk with the dogs if I'm not with
Nina I'm I'm walking faster or running
although Nina can walk really really
really fast for a little person she
walks faster than me so that's that's
epic and I usually have the top 10 rules
in my in my ear as I'm running or
walking getting outside getting some
exercise learning as well right what
what is the thing that gets you inspired
motivated confident ready for action
bold courageous and then doing that
thing in the morning
so I I make my videos still for me I
consume my video still for me and I want
that in my life because
uh so today was Tom bily today I was
listening to Tom Billy and every time I
listen to Tom Billy you I get a little
more bold a little more courageous a
little more spark and so not just hoping
that that happens designing and
Engineering it into your day every day
demanding it
uh and then the latest finish is 10. so
all that has to happen by 10. that can
go super quick
or it can take more time again depends
on when I wake up so from if I wake up
at eight something I go super fast
through but it still gives me the time
to get through it because I don't have
to be done until 10.
this morning I woke up at five something
super easy to get through all this stuff
but I don't set a start time for
anything
because I don't know when I'm gonna wake
up so there's not the pressure if I have
to be outside by X time
I have to be done by 10 and there's
there's no situation where I'm not
waking up
by 10. I can't sleep in that long uh so
this is pretty much
every day
it's pretty much every day
um weekdays for sure most weekends every
day
that's my morning routine my to-do list
the daily routine I'm not gonna go like
step by step through this if you want to
go deeper we can on any of these evil
questions but this is what a weekday
typically looks like wake up the morning
routine that you just saw 10 o'clock I'm
done right 10 o'clock I have to be done
that's music and daily websites music
like why we have Zan here before you
guys get on because look at me so
excited music is the fastest way to
change your state
right and and
Alex comes on and starts singing I can
see clearly now so then Zayn starts
playing the song Tess says she loves
Calypso so Zayn starts putting on that
music for her Zen knows I like salsa so
then he plays that like when you when
you play music that you like that would
force you like Nina was doing her
gardening stuff I was sitting here or
standing here salsa comes on we have to
go dance right there are songs that when
they come on it forces you to get up and
move
and when you do that make it a part of
your morning routine it can change your
entire outlook on the days if I don't
have the music I'm just not as energetic
not as ready to go so what I do is I
have it says Daily website says 25 to 30
websites that I load every day just to
check in on things the first website
is my playlist so I have a believe
playlist on my YouTube channel it's it's
open it's free you guys can look at it
if you want it doesn't really matter
what's on my playlist it's more what's
on your playlist what would you want to
have there and you could do that today
design your playlist so that tomorrow
when you wake up you can just put it on
and it will force you to get out of your
groggy state
because these are songs that would have
to make you get out of your chair think
of the songs that if they came on it
would get you out of your chair we all
have those start your day with it makes
a huge difference 10 30 to 1 3 125 is is
a work chunk and that depends on what
I'm doing for the day Thursday is public
facing day so this is this is why
movement makers is at 10 30.
it's no surprise that's why we're here
it's my work chunk number one so on
different days I have different tasks
but it's always these work chunks
130 to 155 I'm checking email and I'm
doing uh some Social Media stuff two
o'clock IG live uh or insiders group
Live
um so that's my break in between of like
of my different work chunks
um then 230 to 255 and this is every
weekday this is Monday to Friday uh I'll
go out with Nina and we'll go right now
since it's getting warmer we'll just go
to the park take the dogs get some sun
we connect how was your morning uh
because I'm I'm pretty
locked in
for that morning right I'm doing
whatever work I need to be doing
um I'm maybe I'm connecting with Nina
for working on something but it's work
so we take that 25 minutes to go outside
get some sun again be with the dogs just
something that's not work to be together
if it's super freezing cold we might
just go on the balcony taking some fresh
air just something sometime to reconnect
in the middle of the day come back work
chunk number two
it's another two and a half hours almost
of whatever work chunk for the day then
we sit down this is actually a new
addition I don't think I've even talked
about this on any video or anywhere else
where I want to try to incorporate more
sit down dinner time with Nina
I haven't sat down to eat dinner I think
since I was living with my parents
something that that I did since leaving
home since I don't know 18 whatever
whenever whenever I left
um I just defaulted eating Elite while I
work I've never spent time to sit down
and actually eat
um but I wanted to use that time again
to reconnect with Nina and we carve out
it's either 25 minutes sometimes a
little bit earlier depends on how that
work chunk number two goes uh but
between 5 and 5 30 you sit down and try
not to just sit there and work uh and
you know not bring our computers with us
like actually sit at the table and put a
placemat down and and you know
silverware and
actually pretend like you're having a
real meal uh part of that may be because
we haven't gone out to a restaurant in a
year and a half
but maybe we're missing it but also time
to connect again and be together and a
lot of these moments
it doesn't have to take a long time
right the the 25 minutes with Nina in
the afternoon and then sitting down for
dinner it doesn't have to take a ton of
time but I don't know just find that
that's important to to connect
throughout the day not just at the end
then I stream so six o'clock I stream uh
zandeman uh is a co-host uh as well as
Drew and I play League of Legends which
is a video game while we take questions
from the audience about business and
life uh so you can see what we do if you
want tonight Evan carmichael.live six
o'clock Zane's gonna bring more energy
um eight o'clock I I usually play
something with my son we're into
Minecraft right now or he's into
Minecraft right now so I'm learning
Minecraft right now Nina and I will then
watch a show uh right now we're watching
Arrow no we finished there we're
watching Flash and we're watching the
new Captain America Winter Soldier and
Falcon something like that
um 10 o'clock clean up take the dogs out
do more stretching uh take questions I
do my 10 questions with that on
Instagram and then 11 o'clock read and
go to bed
uh I'm a super slow reader my goal is 10
pages a day if I can get that in the
half an hour then I pass it that's a
that's a daily that's my daily to do
this is an extra special topic
self-publishing versus getting an agent
publisher I've got four books two of
them these two were self-published and
that's just through Amazon this one was
with your one word was my first book my
major book that was with penguin random
house that was with a six figure Advance
uh and the typical publishing deal and
then built the serve was it's almost a
hybrid so we did build the serve with
Mel Robbins label uh who she published
the five second rule with and it's it's
a hybrid in that it's it was no Advance
on this one but much bigger royalties
so typically with a publisher you get
you might get an event you might not
depends on how big your your list is and
your audience is
but you get paid very little for every
book that's sold here's I'm betting more
on myself and so less well zero on the
advance compared to six figures on this
one and I get paid more for every book
that I sell so let's talk about how to
pick self-publishing versus publishing
to help you make the best decision it
starts off with what are your goals okay
so anytime somebody's asking me there's
no one-size-fits all like what do you
want to accomplish so I'm going to start
by making the case for self-publishing
here's why you want to self-publish one
you have a bucket list to have a book
some people just want to have a book
it's on their bucket list or they
promise their mom they'd write a book or
they was in their High School yearbook
that they're gonna have a book like if
you just want a book because it means
something to you because you want to
have something on the shelf or because
it's on your bucket list then the
easiest thing to do is just self-publish
it you don't need to go through the
hassle and headache and pain of trying
to go get a publisher just make it
yourself and poof you have your book
if you want to make money from the
actual book then you want to sell
publish because you keep just so much
more of the revenue from each book
compared to going with a major publisher
where you make basically nothing right
there's a small royalty on every single
book sold but if the goal is to make
money from the book itself
you're going to self-publish you keep
just a much much much larger percentage
if you have other goals which we'll talk
about on the publishing side there's
reasons for that but making money from
the actual book or self-publishing
if you want to use it as a funnel for
lead gen
so if you want to create a book it's
fast to set up you then use that to then
get into your funnel to then get into
your coaching to get into your products
so then get into whatever you ultimately
have to sell you have a funnel attached
to it
you'll get a much lower cost with your
own book self-published and you will
going with the publisher so you get your
book for cheaper so it's easier to send
out to people it costs you less to start
building your funnel at that front end
compared to if you get a book with a
publisher
so this is if you've got your sequence
worked out and you know you know your
entry-level product and then your next
level product and then your coaching and
then your Mastermind or whatever that
looks like for you at least having
thoughts of a roadmap a book can be a
great first step in and self-publish
gets you at a great price you get it out
quickly
one of the uh biggest Pains of
publishing is it takes like a year to
get the book out
it's a giant pain
it's other people critiquing you it's
it's slow as anything it takes you a
while to write it and anybody who's gone
through the writing process you know how
long it can take to write and rewrite
and research and edit and all that stuff
but then when you're when it's finally
done it's like okay I'm ready here we go
and then it's another year before the
book actually comes out just because of
how long Publishers take to go through
their machine so if you want to get
something out you know if it's if it's
May right now and you want something out
this year it's not going to happen with
a publisher
so now we're already talking next year
if you want about this here you're
self-publishing you get it out super
fast
you get to be in complete control
so another frustration with any bit of
creative work is the critique to say no
don't don't do that don't put in that
chapter don't call it this I don't like
the name of your book that's not going
to sell very well and it's it's crazy
how little research a lot of the the
organizations do a lot of the publishing
companies do
um when I was picking my cover or when I
was picking the title it's all based off
of their feel there's no Market data
there's no testing with people it's
really just whoever you're dealing with
do they like the concept or not and sure
they have some industry experience so
it's not like a total newbie opinion but
uh it's not it's never based off of what
the audience is actually asking for
needs and they have they have very
little knowledge about the audience that
you're going after so if you want to be
in complete control if you don't want to
have uh somebody telling you what colors
to use what font to use what what layout
to use what Graphics to use what to call
it any of that stuff then
self-publishing is the way to go
you own the rights which is a huge deal
so you can do whatever you want with it
now I've you can negotiate some rights
into your deals if you're working with
the publisher so for example I own the
YouTube rights the social media rights
for my books so I could just release the
whole book on YouTube or on Instagram or
on clubhouse if I wanted to
because I own the rights because they
don't really Publishers haven't really
caught up to that yet we're not thinking
what you're going to put a book on
YouTube
okay sure whatever here you go right
um so you get to own the rights and do
whatever you want with it in the future
so this is the case for self-publishing
these are the reasons why you want to
sell publish okay
publisher why to go with a publisher
what is the reason so one bestseller
list if that means something to you this
is something that's never meant much to
me because you can game the system so
easily to get on a bestseller list
people
literally just buy their way on to
bestseller lists and the way that they
do it which nobody talks about but
movement makers Insider knowledge let's
let's share what happens like how does
somebody get number one status what they
do is they drop the price for one day or
on Amazon it's it's by uh hour they
dropped the price of the ebook version
to one cent
so for one hour for one day they dropped
the price to one cent They then send
tons of people and you can hire services
to do this whether it's your own email
list but they have a whole bunch of
people with email lists but then just
say go buy this book for one cent
ebook and then it blows up off the
charts boom you're a bestseller and then
the next hour drops back down and and
your you know time when the sun is gone
but you can say I'm a best seller so if
if you if you want that just because it
adds some credibility or means something
to you then it's it's a lot easier to do
it with a publisher than
um than on your own
uh Prestige and branding there is still
some cachet to having a published book
versus something that you self-published
it's dramatically dropping this is one
of the biggest fights that I got into
with my agents like you need a book
every need to book everybody need a book
why do we need a book you need a book to
get on stage you need a book to to get
Partnerships you need a book to open
doors like Steve I can open doors with
my YouTube channel
I don't I don't need a book anymore it's
not that books can't help you do that
but there's lots of ways to do that if
you had a big YouTube audience you can
open doors if you had a big Clubhouse
audience there's people who are building
up on clubhouse right now who six months
you've never heard of and they're
getting
Grant Cardone into their rooms and
they're getting Jay Shetty into their
rooms and they're getting they become
they're they're they've opened the doors
they're now somebody just because of the
three months of investment they made
onto Clubhouse so Prestige and branding
can be there it's just dramatically
dropping it used to be the only way or
one of the only ways now there's tons of
ways to be able to build your brain but
if that again means something to you
then publish book still has a little bit
of cachet
editing support
was super helpful of all the things that
a publisher
what you think a publisher helps with
most of them most of the things they
don't but editing was actually really
helpful
so on the editing side I was making
typos I can't believe how many typos I
made
I write it out and I'm I feel like I'm a
pretty good writer you know and not
somebody who failed English class I'm a
pretty good writer and then I would read
the whole thing
and and catch some typos but then I give
to them like oh wow you made so many
times wow I can't believe how many typos
I made it's crazy I even gave it to my
friends and family to go through and
read give it to 30 people each time to
go through and read and they caught some
typos but then still the editors caught
typos
so and there's still one typo in your
one word that made it through that
everybody missed
uh so it's a little sad the editing
support is very real and I think if you
if you can't afford it then you hire
that if you're gonna sell publish you
hire an editor or even just try to find
who is your uh do you have a friend
who's just really really detail-oriented
and great at editing who can help you
you know lend lend an extra pair of eyes
to it
um next formatting support
formatting is formatting especially for
ebooks really sucks you know if you're
if you're creating your book and you
you're making it a Word document and
then you try to translate that to an
Amazon format especially with ebooks
where there's no where it's like
infinite scroll it's such a giant pain
now I I gave it to somebody on my team
for the self-published stuff I said Ray
just figure it out
because it was driving me nuts and Ray
loves new challenges but that took a
couple weeks of his of his life just
trying to figure out how to format the
book to be on Amazon especially for the
ebook and when you go with the publisher
they just take care of all of that stuff
easily for you be in the bookstores
again it's less and less and less
important most bookstores are either
closing down or are supplementing you
walk into a bookstore and a lot of them
are half furniture stores or lifestyle
stores and selling vases and flowers and
a bunch of other stuff so it's not as
important but if you want to get into a
bookstore the Publishers have the
relationships it's not impossible as a
self-published book but it's almost
impossible as a self-published book to
get into bookstores so again that means
something to you if you want to
roll into your Barnes and Nobles with
your family and take a picture you know
view with the book here on the shelves
uh then you have to go with the
publisher
today we are talking about how to grow
your YouTube channel
most of us just aren't posting enough
most of us are too scared or too shy or
are being too perfect and we're just not
posting enough I was on a IG live
yesterday with Dave Hollis
I don't know if you guys know Dave or
not
um New York Times best-selling author a
bunch of accolades and we talked about
his YouTube channel and he just hasn't
been posting you know the last post was
a year ago so this guy is doing speaking
and book deals and you know giant
operations and he just hasn't taken
YouTube seriously and he's just he's
just worried that I don't have the team
I don't know how to do the editing and I
don't know how to do the stuff that
everybody else looks like they're doing
and I told them yesterday just post Dave
just post Dave loves Instagram he's
doing Instagram uh stories he's doing IG
TVs all the time I said you know what
for now just take what you're doing on
Instagram and put it to YouTube
even if it's not edited even if it's not
uh cut properly because Instagram is a
vertical platform just post dude just
start posting post post post I'm gonna
I'm gonna see him in September in Napa
with some of my friends and uh I want to
look at the data I want to look at the
results and say hey Dave how has it been
going and and it doesn't mean that
that's what you're gonna be doing
forever but the biggest thing people are
missing is just momentum just to start
and so I that's what I told him
yesterday just post I'm talking to
um
uh the co-founder of Netflix today at 12
30 on my Ig lives and he started a new
podcast and again YouTube has been not
the priority so I'm going to tell him
like Hey just post your videos on you
why are you not posting on YouTube and
so this is the advice I'm giving my my
Elite friends you know the people who've
done a lot of big things I'm giving it
to you guys as well because most of you
are just not posting enough content and
we need to get out of our way let go of
the editing let go of it being perfect
and just post so Melanie Melanie was the
one who asked this question Melody new
member of movement makers again welcome
to the family great to have you and this
was her channel so she's making videos
about tapping EFT tapping emotional
Freedom tapping I believe that's what it
stands for and one of the challenges for
her is she's just not posting enough
and so if we look at it you know this is
since the beginning of the year tapping
to let go of 2020 that's what's 12
videos
in we're in June now so it's just it's
just not enough so whatever the
whatever the struggle is whatever the
voice in our head that's telling Melanie
whatever the voice is in your head
that's telling you not to post tap tap
it away it'll tap it away and just start
posting and just start creating and just
start making because again you've got a
message in you that people need to hear
and by you convincing yourself of all
the reasons why you're not going to win
and why it's not good enough and you
don't have ideas and whatever the voice
is that we can get into some of them
uh in in the chat if you want uh but
whatever that reason is it's not good
enough because your message matters and
we have to get that voice of yours out
to the world uh so just post like it's
still Melanie's biggest problem here is
she's not posting enough content
okay this is why we did the 100 video
challenge
because I want you to post a hundred
videos before you give up before you
judge yourself before you say you can't
do it and what is so valuable about a
challenge like this is that if you're
committing to making 100 videos you
don't care so much about the last one
being perfect you know you don't worry
about ah did I get it is it good enough
uh did I get the right title because
you're still now worried you're moving
forward next you post and then next post
and then next and what we've seen is
people who've gone through the challenge
you're so much better even 10 videos in
20 videos and 40 videos and you're so
much better than you were when you first
started right when you first started and
we we talked to a bunch of people who've
done it before who've gone through the
100 video challenge you're so much
better I look at Tessa who did a hundred
I forget when she stopped counting she
was 130 or something when she stopped
counting uh she's just gotten so much
better she's like yes I've I I was the
person who never thought I could do it
and here she is now posting hundreds of
videos and so when you commit to making
consistent content
a lot of the fear of being perfect goes
away because you have to get it out even
for me and my channels we're doing 20 to
30 videos a day across the channels and
videos have to go up
we want it to be as perfect as possible
I want to be as good as I could possibly
can be but that's not a good enough
reason for me not to post when you have
a deadline
it inspires you to actually go off and
create videos have to go up so here's my
recommendation for
the calendar so once a week is the
minimum
you have to be doing once a week and
again cut down the editing don't worry
about all of the fancy things just get a
video up every week minimum that that's
your entry into the game that just gets
you into you know the casino that's just
your ticket in to to the lottery or
you're at bat in the baseball game
whatever analogy you want to use once a
week is the Bare Bones minimum so when
we look back on on Melanie she was doing
12 videos in six months or so so that's
what every two weeks so
not quite enough we need to be at least
weekly for those of you who are already
at weekly consistently great now it's
three times a week and for those of you
who are are rated three times a week now
we're going seven times a week then
we're going daily
and I I spaced it out like this because
going daily for some people
is uh scary it's like I'm never gonna do
that there's no way I'm gonna do that
that's impossible and so hey we're we'll
we'll guide you every step along the way
we'll make this happen together just
start with once a week just get some
content up there and then once you start
going it's not that crazy
it's not that hard you know because the
beginning is so much harder because
you're trying to figure out how the
camera works and how to press record and
how to post and all the mechanics and
the nerves and the sweat and the fears
and all that and you start working your
way through it so it becomes easier each
time uh Tessa says I did 162 videos
I love it Tessa uh Belinda says I go
daily now if you look at Belinda go look
at Belinda Belinda Harris on her uh on
her Instagram she's got she's like she
starts Spitting Fire as soon as the
camera comes on now she is hello it's
Belinda she's just like telling you
what's up she's spitting the truth but
if you go back to her early videos it's
a lot more reserved and a lot more you
know just trying to get the message out
so
as you get more practice with it I see
you know Ray Higdon in the in the in the
house too his stuff is getting super
funny he's doing these skits he's doing
these uh you know him Rey versus one Ray
versus another ray like as you start
getting more comfortable with it your
personality starts to come through even
if you don't have a ton of personality
your little quirks your little
eccentricities now I see Tariq in the
house always doing music and Vibe every
video he does is a vibe to it you know
like I know when I click play on a Tariq
video this is going to be Vibe that's
happening right so we all develop our
own little style as we go but we're
gonna be conservative and safe and
boring at the beginning and that's okay
don't think that you suck just because
you are conservative safe born you will
get better okay so just post right
because no other strategy will help you
if you're not posting I could tell you
how to do thumbnails and how long to do
it and where to post and all this stuff
but if you're not actually creating none
of this stuff was going to help so you
guys need to be more consistent on the
posting we're just posting we're posting
content we are creating we're going to
stop getting our heads we're gonna
actually start creating We're not gonna
be perfect anymore we're going to go and
post one more big idea that I want to
share with you the length matters okay
how long are the videos that we're gonna
put on the channel I could dive deep
into analytics and so many things that
could uh that I love geeking out over
but for where most people are right now
it's probably a little overwhelmed so if
you really want to dive deep we have
brand Linux for that but for for this
section the length
my typical advice over the past
three years has been go 10 minutes plus
10 minutes plus 10 minutes plus 10
minutes plus 10 minutes plus use that as
your minimum 10 minutes and if you're a
thought leader you're an expert you can
do 10 minutes all you have to do is is
take me deeper give me more advice uh
share your story share a client story
share something in the news cycle just
share share share with me another story
and share with me more tips on how to
overcome the thing that you're helping
me solve just take me deeper
a thought leadership video that is that
is three minutes long is really really
really really really really hard to get
ranked
pretty much impossible to get ranked if
you do you've won the lottery
congratulations but I want to give you
the strategies that can really help work
for long term so we're looking at 10
minutes plus
uh don't repeat yourself the same you
know just to extend it to get to 10 but
we're finding the best results in this
category plus if you want to watch the
full version of this
train live live with me twice a month to
help you build your movement and be
around some other amazing people just
like you check out my movement makers
program the link to join is right there
next to me can't wait to see you there
continue to believe and go join